oh
finally it works it works
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
well
it's good times i need to do surgery
together
you just met
save some lives yeah no it's awful
oh okay i was just gonna ask if this is
normal for you
nice
okay is everyone in the game
hey
look at this
nice obligatory high fives to start it
off
nailed it
wait wait wait wait
sorry i gotta change my character really
quick how do i do that again
other mirror yeah
ah beautiful
witch doctor um all right
guess i'm milo
great
so much customization there we go
i like this look thank you thank you
all right should we get ghosts
so
so creepy
so have you played this before then
yeah
yeah same same with the me and ken so
i'm curious to
remember
how to do this
why what flashback good flashbacks
come on
okay all right so we can do free-for-all
or story mode maybe free-for-all
should we try that yeah
okay i load it up
oh wait hold on let me just check if
people can hear you guys oh they can't
hear you guys i haven't looked at chat
sorry chad oh my god
i had to say hi and be courteous first
okay now i can ignore them and worry
about my stream
i have like 500 comments saying
all right
sorry
sorry all right guys say something
just hello hello yeah how's the last
levels
professional streaming thank you thank
you thank you all right
we're playing sergeant simulator guys
free for all baby this my pod
okay thank you thank you chippy
i'm ready
oh i didn't press ready now i'm ready
[ __ ] me up
excuse me dang what was that
it's too early for that i'm not doing
late
finding player are we just going to go
with the round
who's joining
um
we should have turned off my voice chat
uh oh chippy join fast
[ __ ]
oh no we're going to get some rain
though
wait
10 left oh you left i can't back oh
there you go
oh
oh bye i think we're good wait this is
competitive
we got some competitive surgery
whoa
there's so many limbs everywhere all
right i'm gonna win this i've proved
once and for all the greatest surgeon
wait am i getting points how do you do
this
i forgot the controls help me
i know they're spinning
dang it that i need his legs
i we all have zero points i'm so
confused
mine really looks like i need to
amputate oh oh we gotta take the limbs
we gotta put them in this other room
over here okay let's help out guys so if
we start with my character
what we can do
oh wait we're different colors i just
ripped these off maybe i just ripped
them off
yank them why it's something easier
are you saying
help me
okay there we go
this is green where's the blue one
oh damn there's no blue color in mine i
don't understand there's one over here
like this side
wedding can't work these
ah
thanks
got it
i feel the competitive's nearness here
this is really uh i don't know
i'm dropping them in i'm stuck here now
what
two inboxes okay here we go here we go i
got the point for you for some reason
like when i put mine into yours oh
really
oh okay the door's open and closed i got
it i caught it here i got a hand
oh i think i put mine in the leg
damn it
i just want one point yeah okay so you
have to put them in like the right one
there's legs and arm buckets yeah
that should have been obvious
i did the same thing okay here we go you
guys let me in
we don't control it
um
okay i'm gonna get a point now i'm gonna
get a point
i'm gonna get that point
oh the doors keep changing
there's so many things that should have
been easy to figure out
it's all pretty obvious we're
look
there we go
where does this go why did i not get a
point i why not what maybe this one over
here needs it stop pushing me
oh my god
why am i i want from me why am i always
the worst gamer did i maybe i took
someone else's lens maybe that was
station
[Music]
thank you
i feel like you didn't mean that then
oh no i meant i meant it oh we're luck
fair
nice
oh wait what i went through all the
trouble of beating felix that was you
didn't beat anyone stop it
you guys got the same score no one won
that means no one won oh did it kick him
out
no what is that what happened to me no
good enough bye-bye yeah
yeah you're not coming back no i'm here
okay
maybe it's just loading
[Music]
i think i hope
no one knows your back you're back hey
cool nothing changed for me that's
awesome
all right the stakes are high
i'll definitely win the next one i
wouldn't worry about it
it's a warm-up this warm-up thank you
thank you
all right now uh ken left
am i supposed to click something oh here
we go now we're going okay sweet
oh
okay okay okay okay it's not all right
let's not
all right intestines arms
what am i
that's legs
the arms gotta go
come on come on come on come on come on
why am i not getting points
i'm not losing
it's not happening it became green for a
sec
i got a point for a sec come on
break it over up
the axis oh no i've oh no
that's the liver on the other i need a
lever
i need liver
i need this intestine
success music dan you've been playing
you've been cheating just say just say
you've been cheating
just say it wait what do i need now i
need
what body part is this kidney or stomach
i don't understand what i'm doing
um yes
let's grab oh you don't know what you're
doing ken uh what a shame what a shame
it must be really hard to figure that
out
oh am i getting points no
wrong oh i need the left arm wrong arm
where's the other what's this one
leg
this leg's coming off
uh
yes
yes i got a point oh yeah no no no no no
who took my leg who [ __ ] took my leg
who did it who took my leg who took my
leg i'm so paced who took
my leg
dare you
you are snake
snake of snakes i can't believe it
you were quiet and i'm like oh great
stop it then
no
can you slap in this game
no do not slap me
oh oh what are you doing there what are
you doing today wait what do we do now
down there
it's annoying enough god damn it what
are you gonna do yeah what are you gonna
do about it yeah what are you gonna do
about it
gosh
they got points
i'm not done oh what do i have to do now
oh my gosh okay
i need the
pinky the saw no axe i need this
oh
sorry sorry then sorry that i'm just
gonna i'm just getting i just want to
borrow it i just want to borrow away
oh i won the winner i won nice
[Music]
i think uh i think you should read that
again it says it says one it says one
then
whoa we're ready to level up yeah
that was beyond frustrating
i never want to do that again
[Music]
oh man
all right i like it though
it says uh ken has left no wait daniel
yeah i'm still flying yeah yeah i think
it's just yeah game thing
[Music]
they're calling me the neighbor's kid
and i can't believe it
this is rude way the neighbor's kid
you're the one that took my leg that's
all i know oh wait mine says lost
connection oh you did leave the party
that time okay maybe to do story
no
come back to me no
all right so how does the twitch
integration works have you guys tried
that yet
i have it on but i don't know okay
let's do anything
i think you may have to re-invite me
again
no come on there you are
no way i should have a i see you feeling
barefinger oh that's so cute
look at this
there we go connection
no like i got him is that your baby i
got the birth i need one
this is huge changing the game
oh i got a bowler head next
i think i'm joining
felix is giving me strong do you have
games on your phone vine what does that
even mean
i think they're calling you bad
[Laughter]
i will not look at it
then are you journey
i'm stuck on a loading screen oh you
should leave and then just i send you a
new inmate
there we
okay uh invite sen did you get it
yeah
okay i might need to restart my game
quick i i
i'm a pro gamer
i think i think ken has that advantage
because uh he's in australia and he has
that like like
that look at that yeah yeah here we go
you get that oh thanks look at my dog
thanks my duck you like that take it
just take it i oh what a cute sound
here eat it
delicious but you ducks in australia you
crazy australians
people duck everywhere we talking about
what but what about the duck sauce where
does it come from
it's duck sauce
you eat duck sauce
fake ducks whenever you get chinese get
the duck sauce oh
no
they would not do that to the ducks
all right they take this duck in these
arenas
they do not
the chinese would never
be careful they're coming for me yeah
can you send me a fresh invite quick oh
my bad
uh
oh what
this already invited you
and i can't send another one
maybe i need to restart the game then
all right let me do it
let me let me do it on the steam
actually invite the game there we go i
did it through steam oh there we go
hold up jesus i'm really hungry
cute
yeah name it
benny
benny benny good name
wait i must have that too
yeah yeah we all got it
how are we doing boy
yo you got bombs
we got bongos hell yeah
yeah how you do it
that's how you do it right there
hit him boys
[Laughter]
this is what all the surgeons do in
their lifetime
deal with all the stress of being a
surgeon
[Music]
oh should we play the actual game maybe
nice it's immersion with my hand
snacks you bring in snacks you're that
hungry
oh wow they're actually oh i can't do
this
stuck okay perfect
it's like the waiting room fruit you
can't actually eat it
uh
creation most the sky's the limit create
your own levels maybe we can try some
community made levels that could be cool
are there any yet these are brand new
us
[Music]
what you are four players someone
betrayed you
let's go
[Music]
let's do a mangas
space surgery that sounds cool
no mommy boys i'm actually being that
quiet gotta push the talk on so i don't
blab you to death
okay i'm starting it
oh boy
oh i see you took my pod huh i'm ready
you took my pod huh i see no my hand is
stuck
in your beard
[Laughter]
oh it's beautiful you're at my mercy
come on man
how dare you
i was sick i didn't see that last time
[Music]
all right
everyone ready for among his party part
one
let's get sauce
not yet not yet we have to figure out
first it could be any one of us okay
all right
anyone says don't press it anyone could
be the killer
it could be anyone
is it just this room
[Applause]
oh wait there's something in here what
is that sound
i pushed it
oh it's the emergency
meeting
alarm
i'm sorry i pushed it it's awful
[Music]
[Applause]
how do you open these things i don't
think you can i'm gonna be real with you
guys i think this map is in it's very
early stages
how do you open these
getting my job here
skip level all right
everyone is saying
everyone it says okay
we knew that true
vote cancel dan did you press no
no
oh my god
apologies
okay i did it
maybe we should play normal levels i
kind of want to check them out
so should we not change that
do we have another map to go to
yeah i added like five five
uh try the vote again
why for you
there we go
10 out of 10 what a great match i think
uh definitely five stars on that one
easy
all right
find bob and heal him uh space surgery
nice chocolate
is the chocolate
create me a bite
you want to feed me you want to say
anything
thank you yeah stop in your face eat it
[Laughter]
quick
this man
oh we can't go through here we need uh
we need a key card okay i got the key
card key cards
okay try it
that's so loud
jesus
well
okay we'll find him
all right this looks like an actual map
that's kind of cool look
at the pudding where's my keycard at oh
this would be a key card somewhere
what's in here
oh wait
oh that sounds suss
you found it the secret wait you
actually found it
oh i found it oh okay the duck who would
have thought the giant arrow was there
there was
hey holy dog
[Music]
you guys just say hi to doc you know
i'll be right there
the thing from the other room what do
they need what do we need
it's like a
oh
i thought it was a glow stick
so dangerous ah
nice duck i like your duck
kiss it
what are you guys doing there hi
oh
oh you guys duck don't come in here
hello
what do you got there what do you got
there
nothing
i like woody from toys i hear him
i'm don't get jealous get in here
you can kiss it too
i thought i was the only one i thought
was special
that is not it at all
that is not even near the size thing oh
my god are you kidding me
let me just wiggle it around a little
bit
maybe this maybe this is an actual glow
stick
that is just a glow stick literally that
was a glove stick
all right we got to go back
don't forget the duck all right
watch watch that ducky
i'm watching it and he's watching us we
need a key card there is another glow
stick here i'm not gonna lie maybe
they're
double
get a bigger glow stick
a glue stick isn't big enough for you
hey
can you actually play chess i think that
changed nope
i was like that's kind of cool if you
actually lift up
all right
is there really no
close like actual useful glow stick
i have this but i don't think it's gonna
work
what is this
wait wait wait i got it i got it i got
it i got it i got it i got it i got it
wait oh you did we got a bunch of
chocolate and another duck so that's
huge
i can't reach the top
who moved this
now we can't go here anymore
drag it out it's okay yeah
through teamwork we can do this
all right i'll help
all right just turn it sideways and yeah
yeah
there we go there we go come on baby
close enough i think i broke my wrist
there we go
oh
oh wow
oh wow we made it through boys
we made it through oh we got the kick
card
nice
i got it huge
huge
don't lose it
i think this is literally just to get to
the the guy we need to save
are you serious no yeah
bob we're coming man we did it we're
coming man uh uh what's with all the
ducks what
the ducks
they're watching you have to go down
here
ah
oh no
i can't believe it help me
all right
yeah just pull it
oh you actually have to
you put it down
oh i thought you had to yank it
all right you guys go
you guys go ahead without me here
sent for help there's a oh there's a
there's a duck having a moment
what's with all the ducks dude excuse oh
occupied sorry okay we got our
instruments yeah
i got the scaffold
oh you can't reach the toilet paper i
got you buddy don't worry there you go
oh wait here's our guy
where is he
he's supposed to come out of here but i
don't know
no bob found
uh a few things
ah
okay
is there one in here i think you're like
maybe we should do an action level but i
feel like we're so close to actually
getting this one
i've got one all right
this is just one that we need
i think so okay nice
i'm so ready for surgery
there he comes oh bob let's
don't do it
stop
[Music]
stop it
nice
i'll protect you bob i protect you but
okay bob has some serious issues his
heart broken stomach i wonder how that
happened
intestine broken
we should delegate our work okay
okay as head surgeon
as self
declared head surgeon
i got me uh dan you're on uh you're on
arm duty limb duty okay
ken
you're meat duty okay
i got the meal
i'll do the head because i'm the head
surgeon of the head surgery there's a
bowling alley up here
uh
oh he's dying he's dying he's he's dying
really i think he's he's fine
he's fine he's fine i mean you rip his
head off no i didn't knock her all right
he's gonna need any blood blood blood
blood blood blood give him blood meat
duty give him blood i got it i got it he
said blue it's there i got i gotta get i
got it i gotta get it he has he has zero
blood loss right i don't think anything
oh never mind yeah he's definitely no no
i save him i'm saving him i'm saving him
he did we did all that just loose are
you kidding me they're enjoying this
level no no
no that was the worst level all right
let's do an actual one screw this excuse
user among us maybe we should go back to
the tutorial no no tutorial i remember
okay maybe tutorial i don't know
i think we did good
who killed him it was you ken
i know it me it was you it's definitely
you you're right
i always hate it bob all right return
always hate him so much
what's your issue
okay we're back in lobbying did we get
any cool new stuff
i don't think so
he died
wow
okay
oh
okay okay so we can now these are locked
okay that's shane because like we've
already kind of done these
well the story yeah
i mean we did
shoot how long ago did we do that should
we try this story
okay yes dude okay
away
all right guess we're leaving bye bye
ken
bye
i don't know
oh my head oh you're fine stop stop
complaining
stop complaining
you're fine
you just had to get that part didn't you
it just had to be difficult didn't you
that's gonna be close to the board yeah
dan has so much more xp than us because
he's actually
he won the one job
poor bob's heart is on its way out
luckily our bioreplicator unit the brew
has produced all right a plus plus gang
let's get it greatest achievement and
works almost perfectly
all right a plus plus we're going for
the a plus plus
okay i'll hold this hand and you guys do
the surgery
[Music]
i think i broke the ribs i did it now i
can
now we can get in there
we got we're taking care of all aspects
of the surgery then
the mental aspect
the emotional siding i think we're
killing bob you don't need that right
bob you're awesome dude
you're so good oh yeah they don't need
that
you don't need that
that one's stuck i'll give them a foot
massage
tickling his mustache oh
well i mean
put it back upside down
it happened there we go it happens
okay
i need a syringe all right let's let's
diagnose diagnose diagnose
and he's in your heart i was like
his girlfriend left him he needed oh no
bob
oh bob here we have some more blood bob
uh do you know where we can find a heart
anyone anyone get a spare heart
somewhere
i i think we need a key college oh okay
oh i gotta get one wait
i'll go back i'll make sure it doesn't
bleed today
i was like three begging this room oh my
old office
i'd rather miss it
hey
[Music]
more blood
more blood this one doesn't work here
more blood i think i've got it
oh so much blood he's not full of blood
what i don't wait oh we have to give his
old heart here
all right i got the blood clot medicine
nice
we only have three of those you're going
to use them all before you have to do it
there oh wait we only get three of them
not bad
yeah
i say i say okay bob wants a new heart
right but what if we also like give him
new cool
legs
right wouldn't that make him really
happy oh you're right yeah all right so
stop the stuff
stop the bleeding let me just stop the
bleeding yeah i got that don't worry
nice yep i'll do it all right and then
we'll get rid of this one too
okay okay
stop the bleeding please
stop it stop it stop it stop it yep he's
yep all right let's
i don't have enough in the serrated
still bleeding uh that's all right we'll
just pump him up we'll just pump him up
let me go juice you up bob
where's the heart at
number it's still in his chest
although the replacement we got the
replacement anywhere
we need to put the old one in there what
if we put his can we can put his
oh you can do that you can do that
wonderful
oh he's gonna be so pleased bonus
surgery
you know
sometimes when you get a contractor to
do something they do a little bonus
that's we're giving the special bonus
now
the signature for our surgery
let me get in there let me get this
heart
oh did he die oh no what why
too much too much blood
oh he lost too much blood i'm like he
got too much blood
i don't get it i thought we
thought we were i mean pretty good sir
we didn't even do anything yeah thank
you level up well done
[Music]
we're just doing bonus surgery and then
he dies that's kind of rude
how do we get worse this game
is on its way oh wait we get wait guys
if we get a plus plus we get a question
maybe we should try and get a plus plus
check the diagnostic skills to see
what's ailing him all right a plus bus
game
[Music]
wait we need his heart we need his heart
we need something to smash
his rib cage uh
oh yeah anything
definitely
it fell off i swear it fell off
it's okay i'm stopping thank you he's
fine
[Music]
thank you damn
what a team
what a team right his eye
i like beautiful oh
he's got that upper body strength now
that he always wanted i know
[Music]
oh he is away he's he's close to dying
he needs blood let's close the dang why
no it fell off it just fell off i don't
know how
get it back on no no no no no no
maybe maybe this is a glitch for me he
looks like he's fine every time i look
at the board really or the uh
yeah
no he's definitely he's definitely need
that blood he need that blood all right
i'll juice him up let's do some up
he needs way more he's way more you're
right
i don't understand like
his bloodlines like
we just
you understand blood loss all the hearts
are the earrings we gotta get his heart
out yeah we gotta juice them up first
all right all right
where's the there we go
there we go the bonus has been the bonus
is done we probably shouldn't start with
a bonus but you know
all right i'll i'll i'll have so we can
stop the blood and you guys can
you guys can
uh destroy his rib cage what are you
doing with that chair
destroying his rib cage okay we don't
have anything we have the right utensils
here yeah we spent all our budget on the
on the bonus aspects oh it works yeah
keep going keep going keep going
come on bob give me that heart
uh
yeah he's doing fine you can keep doing
that
no
there you go we're not doing nothing
there's no luck can we not have anything
better than that
ben how about it
we use
we use them first aid to kill him i mean
break is yeah i mean
oh that looked puff what a sweet irony
huh first aid causes damage
it's almost poetic there we go
all right so now
we're getting very good
well done high five
are you gonna bob a high five escape
uh do you even get some blood for bob i
give him a low tickle actually i'll get
the uh
oh look he's ticklish look at him
little squeamish all right then rip that
heart out i'm ready to stop oh okay i
got i got the bleed i got the bleed
stopper i got the bleed stuff
yeah give him the bleed slapper pump
pump him up real good
let's get him
nice all right is he dying or something
i think he's still dying no he's good
there we go all right
cheers
juice him up
i got him boys you're good you're good
you're good you're good save him yes
julian
you know arms and legs don't belong in
there
what's over here i'm sure it is but
secret projects on your own time please
oh so now we can go oh
wait wait wait wait boys boys bonus
bonus
oh another one bonus what's the bonus we
got all kinds of bonus in here then you
should grab one too bob's gone
grab a bonus
can we put like a leg where his head
should be no
that's too much these rings can we do
that
should we make all legs maybe to iron
out that's a nice bonus julian i've got
a job for you
wait what no
we didn't get to do the bonus
goddammit
oh hey
let's go almost eight plus plus losing
less than ah dang it oh yeah no kiss
trade we didn't do bonuses
someone did that in 19 seconds
that's a speed run
what a nerd
you got the matching oh we all get hat
now we should get them this is huge
you level up again
and we still passed
we killed it we killed it
heck yeah you're in the bathroom
all right
i guess it's up to us stan
we could get a let's just see a crab
what is that a face
face mask i think it's again i think
it's a monster okay
huge that would be huge
all right let's show ken just like that
we are the ones pulling all the work
right
let's do it
oh bob is here right away nice
all right speedrun surgery
oh this is easy he just needs new arms
we can do it easy all right all right
all right where's his arms where do we
have to put the where's his arms oh he
hasn't got much blood though ah no one
is blood we kill him already what are
you guys doing
excuse me
showing you how it's done oh my god
does any i like how do you feel
okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
okay guys i got him what i got it
here grab it grab the leg grab a leg leg
okay okay
he wants new legs so we give bonus legs
as well right
i'm gonna yank his head off see if you
can replace it
[Music]
yes
can we put his can we put his head here
because i think he'll probably want a
head
right yeah okay let's see
[Applause]
that's bonus we do bonus surgery here
hey good job bob
looks so happy too
he's gonna have a great view
and we barely lost any blood i think
honestly
if you guys want to start a surgery like
if you get tired of youtube or something
just
i think with the right investors and
the right people behind it we can really
make some real change in the world
all right
who would what are we supposed to be i
like how he keeps his shorts
no no i barely touched it i barely
touched it i barely touched it
quick
put something on there oh my god
he's fine oh he wanted new arms
i got one oh i know
he's so picky
what felix is that performance anxiety
because we're playing the game with dan
yeah
yeah it's okay don't tell him yeah all
right i'm pretty sure i can hear you
no
where all the arms are there's no arms
they're depleted i think wait what
where are we going what is it
don't worry ken here i'll let you do it
so you can show dan that you can do it
oh wait we just need weed arms though no
the arms are in there in this room over
here yeah behind the glaze
oh but why why does he want arms when he
can have legs
legs
oh this is the one we got through the
ball over the top i remember this one
leg
he's like a
half a spider it looks like a half-life
monster like the spider crime
look at this big brain
no why does its head keep falling off it
keeps falling off
[Music]
all right do we have any more blood uh
i i'll i'll hit him up with some blood
where's the old are we can we go through
here
i'll juice him up some g fuel
make him live real good
when he leaves here he'll be a true
gamer oh boy
he'll be like
we created the ultimate athlete it's all
leg
yeah i believe it just sprints so fast
i got a left arm boys i did it yeah
let's go well done ah
we got no space let me just let me just
juice him up real quick hold up there we
go yeah yeah give him a juice
maybe i need you to lift rip off his
right leg which is this one then can you
do it three wait i could i could have
stopped bleeding
oh no get on there quick i'll stop late
i'll supply
you're welcome guys where's the other
arm at uh it's in there is it
it's in the now we gotta you gotta use
the old one to get the new one it says
you can still get one there was one
somewhere
yeah i think i got it all right all
right all right
yeah it looks like from the forest the
creatures you're right
oh yeah
the cannibals
all right uh
we can keep the old stuff too guys
we can keep the old legs use that on the
next guy
no we didn't get the surgery man
are you kidding me why oh we're oh five
seconds we were five seconds quicker ken
if you weren't deadly dabbling
for that the bonus actually gave us
bonus
are higher level than me
let's go
why my highest level because i tore up
for his limbs
guys you don't understand the surgery
okay
obviously let me explain you've taken to
the unique nature i kind of want to
change my outfit now
yeah same
damn good luck
let's do
yeah
oh guys we got a timer we got a timer no
no whiff laughs
no way
freezer
oh the freezer's full of berries nice
all right
all right i got the esky yeah
what is that even oh you dropped it
already spilled my beer how could you
sorry sorry mate try to have a good time
oh wait i think can someone push me
through here and then i can go
no we have to we have to transport no no
no no no we transport the things through
there oh it's just the one we're gonna
handle yeah so like if you want a chair
i can i can put it in for you we're
still gonna push the button on the
inside there oh that's true
oh wait this there's a door here
are we in
no
what's going on how do we do this this
door is locked
i'm going up
i guess you'll need an arm to get
through an arm
i can sacrifice my arm
they're in the freezer
oh excellent arm i don't know where
diane is gonna be i'm here i'm here
there we go there's an arm follow me sir
ah yes
to my office
please place arm oh i see you i see all
right
my dear brother's old office
her brother is all about oh he's getting
lower oh wait can we jump through here
we can jump through there
we're in boys
yeah i see a ball oh wait some one
person has to
not go through right
wrestling i will go back if i figure out
how to go back
oh button
oh you're going straight in okay
i was rotten it was running
it was run night i promise it was fun
it's important to have a healthy diet
before surgery that's right yeah yeah
yeah
what do we need a leg and an intestine i
gotta wash them up real good too
people don't clean their insides you
know what i mean
it's true
um
[Music]
i'm sorry we have to give him the old
parts
i'm afraid you'll need to
it's improvise like soaping up when you
do it
because uh it's the most i think it's
the most important part of sir
what are you doing in there what are you
doing in there
all right what is he i need his old
party what do we need he needs a new leg
please and i already changed the arm
yeah he needs a right leg so
pass me his right leg so i can pass you
back a new right leg okay but okay okay
okay
then do you want to do the leg pull and
i'll uh i'll stop the bleeding yeah yeah
which leg left leg
okay we got it we got it we got time
this is very delicate delicate
take it's going green
what if we
he has a syringe leg then he can never
stop did you give me the bleeding yes
oh there it is
let's get your leg never stop bleeding
yeah yeah
oh thank you
all right and then he also needs a let's
grab it uh what is that uh left arm when
he came up why
uh
what
it's bleeding to death then
okay we're good okay it's it's fake so
yeah
left arm that's right
let me juice him up
give him the juice oh hello there sir
a little sketchy uh passing limbs
through a little uh ventilation system
but
yeah oh no no no help help
oh no wait wait hold up put them back in
put them back in no what no i'm sorry
i tried to juice him up and his legs
fell off
they both fell off whoever did
who who inserted the new leg
yay
did you forget to sew them back together
not bad apologies do you forget
did you use tape
instead of use the duct tape
i just spilled it that's what i did did
i go down in level for that what the
[ __ ]
yeah
that's as mean man
we can get a sexy nurse outfit guys if
we do this right
let's stay on the eyes on the eyes on
the prize speed run
all right stan you get the arm
i'm getting on ken you do what you did
last time you did great
okay i'll just stand here until you guys
get the dirty
i mean it could be because i grabbed a
hold of syringe you're using it and it
was making it glitch from the hole come
on dad speed run away from me
let's go let's go
speedrun surgery
the more people we can be patient on the
more money we can make all right ken do
you have a do you have a leg ready
i can't get it until you give me the
other leg all right start with the leg
then oh okay
three two one leg
oh wait i missed three
three two
oh it's already rotten dude that's
disgusting
all right i'm supporting i'm giving
emotional support
uh what's next uh
left arm left arm
leg oh you got to put the leg back on
leg
oh you got twist there we go there we go
all right left left arm down left arm
pull it just pull it again this outfit
i'm going to juice him up real quick
hold up boys
juice him
can't grab it
oh chair get out of the way
he's doing fine he's doing great
oh there we go um oh he's doing great
there's a large intestine uh so it's the
blue one i think uh i can use blue or
green for this all right
hello can you
can you rip it i'm gonna do it do it
that is not is it
i'll smash i'll smash
what oh my god you are so pro oh my god
we didn't even have to break his rib
cage
get him so good this anyway sweet
improvements dropped on the ground
this is this will be this will be the
bonus
i got it i got it yeah
nice speed speed
sexy outfit
[Music]
come through the hole
we finally saved the light what do you
mean fine
yes we
that if we work together
we can do anything we can do anything
and we can be sexy nurses now the
question is do we go back to the lobby
just so we can check out our new outfits
i think yes absolutely
right absolutely yes wait what was the
level 5 what happened
uh
not such a good nurse we can get cute
hat thing though should we get that
first nah return to lobby
has some trials of her own going on
somewhere in labs gotta be sexy nurse
all right all right i want to see you
guys in your best outfit
it's not a sexy nurse
what is this garbage
this is no i was promised
ah
i mean
i guess it's subjective isn't it
okay
i don't know i was a spamming can
it's so weird
i brought some uh
some jello
stop typing can you weirdos what are
they doing
thank you
must be my
birthday oh
did you tell them something ken you told
them something i didn't tell anybody
i'm on twitch right now yeah
all right we could get a cute bag outfit
oh backhand
we had a cool like
uh suit that was on fire last time we
played this but i don't remember how we
got it what we did play for quite a
while
we'll see if we get it but if we speed
run i mean we're three people
they pranked me they said they pranked
me good prank guys
really had me going there
we started this on our own
there's no limit to what
youtube chat is capable of
we got 10 minutes uh easy peasy
all right she's making real progress
bob's here what's wrong with you
oh we don't have the scanner yet
don't worry boys and martial you got the
scanimate
i'm just
pulling up in all the
all right we need the
we need to defuse things yes
where are we gonna go in here if i can
get this open oh
nice uh where is fuse
please pretend let's see there it is
is there anyone
we might have to inter interchange
oh wait there's there's definitely
something behind here
oh we can get the new heart from here
keep this box out of the way there we go
secret door oh there's loads in here
all right this is the
syringe of blood we got stoppers
uh
how do we get in this oh
oh we got brains do you have the do you
have the diagnostic thing in there
oh uh
oh yeah we gotta bring it in here don't
we
i didn't see it though no
hmm
[Music]
so maybe if we use the fuse on the other
door we oh here it is okay never mind
well done getting the fuse in guys
okay can you
okay look it's a delicate piece let it
go
if you just let go i could do this okay
all right all right good
looking there we go teamwork
oh my god
10 minutes 10 minutes 10 minutes
i can't help it it can't have that yeah
i do
oh my god look what you did you did that
one too
okay i got it i got it
you got it
oh wow
that's great okay i had the other guy's
hand over
oh that actually worked
never mind
okay ken
10 minutes come on 10 minutes all right
10 minutes come on trying to nudge it i
don't want to nudge it
come on just nudge it no hair i'll
notice your back
pull up okay i'll just hold it okay just
hold it
here
okay
oh we need the syringe room wait
swear
that
what do you mean
i thought we were nudging it i thought
you were holding it i thought you were
holding it did you lose it i thought you
were holding it
you said you were holding it here i got
it i left you for two seconds there we
go it's not that hard it's really not
that hard
all right see you it is with you around
we need some blood
don't worry i'm bringing it
all in here
can we give him a new brain bonus time
bonus
oh bonus brain
why are you doing why are you being like
this
give me that i was moving the chairs in
case we get guests
oh sorry
obey
all right guess we don't
[Music]
we need
stomach leg we need yeah stomach leg
heart
where the stomach's at see liver
heart wait that isn't a brain what is it
10 minutes guys wait wait what is
supposed to be the that's uh that's the
intestine i think oh
i'm sure this was a brain
here comes a stomach
oh excellent
that's a weird way to phrase this
is that prime delivery
oh it was quick yeah nice same day
uh which legs
thanks for the new heart basis i won't
ask where it came from
right lego left leg
uh
hey ken can you come through and help us
over here actually that'd be great
can you just uh chill out a little bit
i'm getting you all the body parts for
your surgery doctor oh oh oh so sorry i
was just wondering if you could all the
heart is on this one if we get it oh
oh what a listen to me shut up
oh you drop you dropped you dropped it
yeah i dropped it
all right
come
oh my gosh every time i have to do this
it's getting oh my god
[Music]
all right guys come on please
please
give me 10 minutes
oh he almost died we need blood oh blood
right here got it right here
we need the juice
his legs come off his legs come off his
legs oh he's dead
what happened
what do you mean i gave him blood
yeah you gave him too hard his leg fell
off
no
let me try slime
all right guys
no more whiff whack
oh nice go get your friends man oh nice
that's mine you discerning
even though you killed him
i also need to decide to troll now
what please forgive the interruption at
the end let's go guys 10 minutes
10 minutes 10 minutes
nina has some trials of her own going on
somewhere in labs she's making real
progress all right we need the fuse
is the diagnostic scanner julian
hey give me get that for you
oh i'm sorry oh i'm sorry
i'm trying to get someone getting a
little annoyed
someone get a little frustrated
right
maybe maybe someone's just picking on me
on purpose
all right
get in there all right get the fuse
please pretend you're not seeing this
oh nice we're just watching him do it
can you open this
i'll do it it's fine
get off me no no i got you man
here i got it i got it i got it i got it
okay all right so if you just open that
up if you just open it
stop trolling please what's happening
all right
i won't stay in oh my god
so what do we uh we need another one
what do we need
i'll make a little care package
get in there make a little care package
there we go you never know what you need
so i'll
that one's in there where's the other
one
i'm making a little
you bulked it up yeah we're just
yeah just put like a little you never
know when you need a new
whatever this is
a little picnic basket you know
like loot crate yeah exactly
monthly subscription
wouldn't that be great what else can we
fit in there
thanks good great i got a new lung i
needed a new liver
oh
a little rib case all right
oh that's so annoying
it's fine five
five second rule by second raw
grab the the unnamed organ the unnamed
organ
okay watch me drop it
oh
let's go
whoa what is this i think we can send it
through this conveyor belt
why can't we just walk it
we could do that too
the transport needs work
i got two strong
legs every time i stand up it just fly
it broke my
what line of sandwich can we make i
don't know where this came from oh
all right some liver
maybe
stomach duck sauce
duck sauce on it
hey ken
hey again what hey when you hungry we
know you're working hard out there and
we got you a treat okay
so show us a little something something
to show we
oh
oh okay wait wait sweet what did you
give me a little something something
you want to come here and show me oh
that was good i think you have to come
in because otherwise it's gonna it's
gonna fall apart
oh
well you see there's a problem the
door's locked
ken stop being so ungrateful come and
get your sandwich
we won't be on it i don't want it
oh so we're both locked in here oh okay
oh i have the turntable oh no
the table turn
okay so what do we do then
can
please
all right we're sending we're sending
through
we're standing through
oh
we're standing there there we go
[ __ ] you can make the sandwich yourself
fine it's our sandwich oh yeah some
bread nice
my favorite
all right we're sending through some
goodies ken
okay
ooh a brain oh no
oh no
then i don't
know if that fits but fine oh if it's if
it's
excellent
good call
good idea okay
do you think they want because you know
it's cold here and
you know it might not be cold over there
we'll see oh my god well if we send
through the ice then
you can eyes on himself
a true huge huge brain huge that's huge
all right there we go that's a massive
brain right there
wait is this definitely stuck
okay what if i go through the conveyor
belt if you just push me in
sorry
good first give it a good wedge
[Music]
i can't get you through can you put like
a uh i don't know like a heart and a
stomach in there oh oh now we're being
specific
i mean you know if you see one laying
around
okay i got you did you put a heart then
yeah okay here comes another is gonna
make it there though this is this is
liver do we have a stomach i think we
used
is this one
it's got to be a stomach here somewhere
can uh try this i don't think i think i
think i sent through the stomachs
already do you see any on the floor
no
wait wait wait i got one here's the
stomach
oh no okay it's coming again nice
it's stuck
it's definitely stuck we got to restart
we definitely shouldn't be this this is
trash
oh wait
we can reverse it let's see
oh no way
now we can
yes we can dude
that is
well it's still stuck the other thing
that thing yes
oh no it fell down it fell down
we're good we're good okay now now back
all right stomach another oh wait that's
the wrong way okay stomach coming
kenny are you getting it
huh you getting the stomach oh yeah
okay
oh he's he's doing great
he finally got down into his stomach
okay how do i stand up without this
flying everywhere
oh my gosh oh catch it
that was huge all right
hearts coming
did you get the heart look at that
freshly iced freshly iced freshly cooked
well done what uh what a team here give
him here water team give him here
give me a little squeeze
okay nice
[Music]
oh my camera died
oh no
that's a good camera exactly what's the
point
gonna need a bulb update uh can anyone
can send a camera through he's hanging
in there
huh i'm just kidding
i can just reach this heart why can't i
reach it
gosh we're doing everything aren't we
then um
no no you guys are doing so good right
now we're not getting fed anything
it's not fair
we're out here doing all the work while
the surgeons we gave already a piece of
breath
surgeons are the ones getting all the
big though
the big money are you going out here
i'll let you out
that's enough wait you had us locked in
on purpose
are you kidding me of course unreal that
is
well maybe i'll let you out please
please
please your australian accent i mean
thanks man you're the best man
all right everything's ready all you
gotta do is pull out his heart in his
stomach and replace him oh
that oh no oh cool let's just find it oh
yeah so this is where it all ended up
cool
all right got his heart
i got a new
i got a new heart
just pull it just pull it bro just pull
it bruh
oh an extra just put an x-ray where does
this get given to you in two hearts
oh no the almost
sorry
he's dying that's all right
after after all that of me trying to
keep him alive and get a plus plus you
guys are going to mess well no no no no
no no bone it just finished
oh god
bonus stomach he just needs to see a
bunch he'll be like a cow there we go
done
and then the like no
did you do that i don't think the yeah
then i don't think the bonus singing
works i gotta be roller with you okay
i'm pretty ungrateful
all right you you pull there we gotta
remove the old yeah diane had this idea
that we gave him his heart ready
new heart where's the new heart
is it in there no oh god
oh no
it begins
i messed up i've messed up we should
have stayed in the freezer
how do i know if the heart is sad or not
you know
oh yeah the heart's done
heart's good we need the stomach okay we
just gotta pull out the other one okay
it's kind of hard to get it he's
bleeding a little bit have we got any
blood uh
yeah i'm trying to get a stupid dude but
i mean
i can't get a grip because like it's
really
do we have a fresh stomach where is it i
put it in there we go there's there's
something is it done is stomach done
something's not done yeah yeah stomach's
done man it's gotta be done right why
does he have four stomachs oh my god i'm
glitching out i can't get in here now
stomach then
did i pull out his kidneys was that not
his stomach
isn't it the pink one the little pink
one
but it's in now
yeah it's a little pink one there's the
heart
back in yeah yeah good good
oh do you put it back in the right spot
that's what you gotta do
why does he have so much stuff happening
here like yeah pull that out
[Applause]
that was huge that was huge
so
i bet you you know we have quite a few
people watching right there has to be
some actual surgeons
well i was gonna say statistically that
has to be some surgeons watching right
now right and i'm sure they're yeah kind
of oh yeah oh they're impressed they
have to be jealous
i'm living with the surgeon right now
i'm surprised
look what we can get if we get a
bob's face
[Music]
don't worry everything is fine
he just needs an arm that's a really uh
there's probably a multi level one
there's another which which arm uh the
right one
yeah okay right arm on the way boss man
he buzz
can i get it right oh that's not creepy
just crawling out with an arm
you know me
that's his left arm
which one do we wait
his right arm it was his right arm oh my
bad
yeah check that junk off man
a wee bit basic
a plus plus plus plus a plus plus
dude this australian lag is bounces me
all over the level
baby
hey
after this maybe we can go bowling
yes uh
oh wait we have the parkour oh no way
i'm bringing the bowling ball because
you never you never know when you need
you know i mean
you just pushed me
no pulling ball
no
okay throw it up here
throw it throw it up
throw it i'm gonna go hold it up
throw up the catch throw it to me okay
again that was close that was real close
i'm ready i'm ready i'm ready to catch
you why is this blowing him right
i'm ready
then i'm ready
yeah yeah charge it whoa yeah that was
sick
oh no no
no no
okay okay okay
wait we supposed to go down these whole
things yeah yeah there you go
i think can say you
yeah what's up hey look what i got look
what i got
get your ball at my face
i'm sorry
i don't want your balls in my face i had
doors open
let's take this with me just in case
can i help you
[Laughter]
sorry
my bad
look not in front of dan okay so
okay
i saw everything
yeah i do like this
you want us you want to trade i trade
your bowling ball
excuse me
take it back
oh there you go
what is happening here fellas
a cylophone oh
rip it up come on play it bruh
i'm trying to pick up a little mouse
just break up the mouth
oh
wait maybe maybe if i hold it it'll
sound better
okay okay yeah yeah oh my gosh
can you just hold it
there you go
oh yes
mary had a little lamb
free stuff freestyle
little lamb mary yeah
[Music]
this book
oh
who ate all the pie
all right are we supposed to grind the
fuse maybe we're doing
hey i was bringing
the extra one where'd that actually go
here i got it i'm holding it
i got
[Music]
[Applause]
nice
huge
what
you get
you're doing great
how do i get keep it get it tonight
we gotta let it
go where is it
are you okay
there we go oh wait
there's another thing in there how do we
do that do i rotate this thing what do
we do
oh yeah that works that works
use the wheel
all right which way i gotta rotate this
this way
nope
oh guys
yeah did we do it
i don't know it closed again
well the one felix is pulling on opens
and closes oh really the fuse fell out
so that's why that's not working what
the [ __ ] i put it in the hole
i got one other one okay
did you put it in the hole
there it is
yeah there it is from
okay which one do i gotta rotate this
thing let me
let me just grab it let me know what
you're doing is working
on arm oh
i got the fuse guys a skeleton arm but
along the way some of us lost sight of
the important things oh yeah the story
starts getting weird i remember this
scary oh my god
look at this come here okay what is that
oh of you oh he's got a huge um
he's got a huge bone bone thank you
hey
don't worry guys
i took it away you're good yeah thank
you
oh i was so scared it was intimidating
what happens
i think we're stuck in here now we're
not yeah
no or not as you put it back in the way
get out get on my face what am i doing
what am i doing what am i doing
everything yeah
yes
oh nice flashlight
link in case you guys scared oh good
call scared
i can't
i can't go through
can you push me
oh is this the can you push are you in
there you go okay okay stuck on that one
go go
i brought it so far
all right well i guess oh maybe we'll do
this i got a spare oh there's so many
[ __ ] fuses dude
oh
hey bob hey bob
bob what's wrong with him we don't know
bob see what does this button do
oh
we can move it
hearts
how do we know what we need though
it knocks it off there
uh we gotta find the little
oh this door's open the scanner
uh bounty i'm just i'm making sure he
doesn't go anywhere
you're doing a great job i found the
thing
gotten the money how's the twitch
integration going is that for free he
needs a large intestines
yeah i don't
know what up with this head
actually have to hold it
clean up
all right i'll just hold it i guess
oh to scan him yeah what's that this new
guts new intestine
yeah
double intestine reach
what does reach nice
no
not quite
there we go
i have one intestine
hey catch
all right
oh that was perfect come on i got it i
got it first try holy crap no balance
this one we already have all right
whoa you need to work on your technique
just a little whoa
i'm looking inside my own arm right now
this is so trippy
right
i've never done this before man
does it look weird on your camera
because it looks real weird on mine
it looks like you're staring into your
regular arm yeah that's it that's that's
what i do
all right what is in what are you
needing oh my god it keeps happening
i think i broke my
arm i need an intestine do you need a
new one a large plenty of lards where's
the small ones we need a large and small
i think these are the small ones the one
that looked like brains
oh i don't think it's a brain
you're right yeah yeah
there's no small intestine jk they're
everywhere
all right we rip it out no no no we
gotta use the tomahawk
excuse me
if you call it all right pull the brain
out
i missed all right guys 360. oh no
don't just stop no no no no no no no no
no i got it out i got it out guys i got
it out just put it back in
i think i'm just trying to
there we go saved
oh that test fell out oh my god he's
bleeding uh i'm we're good we're good
can be an emotional business you call
yourself a professional
i'm the i'm the best one in the business
okay you're all amateurs compared to me
that's gonna be worth an a plus no
not even an a oh with 22 seconds if you
guys stop messing around so much
my guy's about to strangle you right now
but hey guys
but i mean come on
that's not fun
okay
i'm not getting any outfits
sorry you can do it again
a plus plus is kind of sick though
would be sick
we can't let them lose any blood
okay but i'm really good at stopping
blood so i think we can do this
yeah we put that on display the last one
what do you mean
all right guys i got the fuse what are
you guys doing what are you guys doing
to help i got the fuse uh flashlight i
got flashlight
then i'm breaking down what are you
doing today
yeah yeah
all right break the breakthroughs faster
please
all right i'm breaking them all right
flashlights okay give me a flashlight
give me flashlight you can zoom round
burn put it too big put it into bin
but it doesn't fit it doesn't break okay
i'm trying i'm trying i'm trying and
trying okay okay it's insane
all right guys communicate communication
comes what do we got what have we got
machine machine
machines
coming back to ring views i bring it
faster because i got better clicking all
right oh yeah yeah yeah
all right putting it in go to the back
right now okay all right then once it
comes what's it called machine
uh
[Music]
south west east
how many takes
got it got it got it spot it spot it
we'll put it up put it up now
got the rocket breaking breaking
breaking ribs okay so diagnostics bob's
sick bob's sick and repeat bob's
guys guys if you're not talking to each
other if you're not talking to each
other this is not going to work
quick
all right
you need to look at this new legs new
arms
new legs new arms a stab eight side
who's got legs who's got legs
who's got legs
machine is more complex than expected uh
we need three fuses to get bounce free
three fuses
uh all right let's calm down
on the fuse
we need three we need three three triple
we need triplets
okay i'm checking the boxes
uh flying everywhere didn't work all
right uh chicken upstairs
another okay all right checking in here
checking in the other room
i don't know i don't know we're upstairs
we're on top oh then if you come back in
here i found the fuse this is huge if
you hurry up then i need you huge dan
this is walking across where you're
walking across this way all right comes
got a fuse if you oh
okay i'm tossing it to you chucking it
huge that was huge that could have been
huge
massive
[ __ ] i'm whipping
i'm waffling jump in the throat i'm
whipping
i'm gonna wipe us uh this is now this
could be game break they're gonna wipe
it
i'm i'm freaking out i'm choking that's
the word thing
all right doesn't it
oh oh that was huge that was huge that
was huge i mean i could have just gone
through here i realized that now but
okay
we're pro gamers we do this all right
how many more how many more guys we need
two more guys please
two more let's do anything
can we get this together two more how we
possibly gonna get two more
where am i all right gabe we got another
one over here we got another one over
here
i can borrow this that one borrow that
one we got one borrowed we got one part
got a teddy bear ken we need you
to get the lies to use other exploring
we're explaining all right foundation
we need that fuse can we need that fuse
what's your columns please
what's your cons
we're carrying right now
i don't see a fuse i don't see it i'm
glad
so i put in the wrong way it's all right
so right i got you don't worry about it
bro
gary's in here hey you got carried bro a
flashlight
what's your earnings i found a secret
room but i don't know
whatever this is isn't this where we
came ken is choking
bob's done oh my god bob what are you
don't watch your arm
why was no cops on bob who is not on bob
healers
all right we're good okay we're fine
he's fine we're not getting we may have
lost a plus plus but we can still go for
a plus
we can't use the elevator because uh we
took the features the last few years
there's a room in here guys oh that's
where we came from
uh we can pull this lever oh there's
some blood
found some blood juice and bob okay give
him a bottle
all right i got a saw i found a saw guys
if anyone needs a song
let me know
bob's juiced all right i'm going to saw
his legs off guys
i think we can do
it right you're doing a great job
there's no fusion okay guys what's your
comments because we're gonna we're gonna
lose real quick
uh there's some there's some idiot
that's killing bobby thompson
[Music]
you found the fuse
okay i found the fuse
oh what a shame we're close that was
close good attempt guys don't let it get
down we'll get it next time
that was huge
uh just because we failed you know
we're improving rapidly i can tell
we're gonna win the tournament
that's great
we can be like the phase team this is
definitely clan worthy
performances
where's my card all right ken i gotta be
really with you here all right now that
we're done
where the [ __ ] was the [ __ ] fuse
where was he
where was the fuse i don't know i gotta
go watch a youtube video about yourself
in the [ __ ] all right guys all right new
one speed one come on speed run speed
rude speed on everyone know they're
precise
we don't need light no flashlight we're
doing new flashlights right no one
updated no one updating me
[Laughter]
oh dude bro
bro oh bro bro garo get down get the
elevator down get the elevated man
get the elevator down get off the
elevator
get it down get it done get it done get
it done get it done okay okay okay throw
the machines down
got it got it huge i know i know where
the other fuse is this is huge
how'd you get it back down
dude we're getting we're gonna get the
outfit don't worry about it come on
[Music]
bob's good bob's bob's good bob's good
good comes good comes comes on bob
all right i got fused
he's in okay we can borrow one from the
elevator but we need one more
wait what's this
wait guys guys guys guys you're not
communicating guys guys
what is happening right now here's the
call callouts okay we have this fuse do
we have any other don't take it we need
one okay well then we gotta look
upstairs
who's upstairs all right then go go go
go go go
go go go communicate communicate
maybe it's right in front of us all
along you know
maybe maybe the fuse is inside of us
we got a spark inside him wait wait wait
wait wait no no that was not it that was
not it okay okay okay
the fuse has to be up there guys i've
looked everywhere down here
oh
pushing buttons pushing push buttons
okay
secretary hole okay guys guys guys guys
guys guys guys if you're not
communicating guys guys guys
all right
oh this one over here one more looks
looks like uh oh
it's starting one arm
you got an arm arm securely nice bring
that
how do we end up with two of these you
gotta be real with it anyway uh this is
the right arm with the guys
he needs the right arm so gotta be right
oh can we put the arm here i got it
going in for the arm i gotta be real
give me arm give me arm oh no this is
supposed to back here
what do we do with this
where is his bloody dame bloody bloods
fuse man where is it where do we put
this
we had two last time yeah but we need
three
it's it's bloody
hello hello
confused confused okay me too i'm
confused getting a little disappointed
getting a little
run down not gonna do it
what the [ __ ] is it
this sucks this speed run sucks you're
the great comms guys
bob
[Music]
all right well we got a thing all right
guys think outside box outside box
thinking
how's that box
there's like an arm machine here but i
don't know what to do with it there has
to be in here it has to be in the arm
machine
there's this like thing here
it's a trap door
what is
giving these things power
yeah right it has to be in here it has
to be in here
uh
jesus has to be in here here it is
press the button
yeah we got the arm from there we got to
create a we got to create a circuit by
pressing the button
oh ooh
who's this is how we get down here yeah
it is
oh we got there's five more this machine
that's crazy
good job you did it you closed the door
sarcasm is not going to help the team
[Laughter]
oh sorry
is everything back
did you get the arms at least did you
get the arms at least we got one arm
changed we've got one arm
going
upstairs can someone set me up
does anyone have lunch does anyone have
a
wait
positive attitude
oh
here we go we got another i got another
arm positive attitude
got another one this is great nothing
but w nothing but wins
no else no else
all right
where do i put this on yeah i got it got
it got it got it got it got it got it
got the arm pull it out pull it up what
up pull out the arm pull out the arm
pull out the arm pull out the arm pull
out the arm
all right put it in
maybe now maybe now epic win epic win
epic win uh that didn't fix wrong arm
wrong arm wrong arm give oh
left arm left arm put it in put it in
huge wins this is hold on
oh this is right arm we need less down
guys yeah the right arm here we replaced
this one i guess it was the wrong one
what the heck
only wins only wins
this machine
here we're too dumb
we're too dumb we can't do it
just give him two right ones he'll be
fine
here's another one
all right here pull off his right arm
again i got another one to replace it
i'm on it i'm on it high fives high
fives
oh that was huge he is bleeding to death
now okay cool cool cool cool he's good
he's good you're good and he's gonna
leave he's gonna still
oh is it the which arms messed up are
they both good
we need the left replacement we need to
replace this one here
oh yeah he's got a right arm on his left
eye okay
i'm just an idiot you replace the wrong
arms that's okay that's okay mistakes
are happen don't hold it against the
team or the teammate did you take the
fuse you took the fuse i can't take the
elevator stolen
you only got two fuses what are you
doing it's called it and comes in cold
linen comes
are you in the elevator
are you in the elevator are you in the
elevator are you in the elevator i can't
i don't know if you're in the elevator
because you're not giving me calms okay
all right i'm taking it back then i'm
taking it back i'm putting back the
views then
okay
now what what are you doing there what
are you doing dang dang hi
i have a button that does nothing
oh the comps are all messed up this is
never going to work this is never ever
going to work guys we're never going to
be a client insurgent simulator
i gotta be real with you guys
that was just a test and you're not
updating comps you're not updating arms
even then
i can't do this i can't do this with you
guys
i'm sorry
i'm sorry but this team is unbelievable
i'm sick of you
all right guys guys guys quick breathing
exercise for a minute
all right slow in
okay good energy good vibes lower that
heart rate
what are we missing i don't [ __ ] know
this is ridiculous
there's this bit we haven't used yet but
it just doesn't work oh wait it's up
here these vents up here do we need a
stack box oh maybe there's another room
uh oh barrels maybe barrels
fuses upstairs
we can't use the elevator because
someone i took the fuse because that's
my comms but if you call that condoms
next time that's a barrel don't don't
hurt me yeah i'm trying to stack it
don't hurt me
all right dan what are you doing
i'm replacing okay i'm going upstairs
what are you doing now
still replacing fuse
going upstairs heading
uh
trying to look for armhole
don't forget to breathe guys don't
forget to breathe guys
stacking barrels yeah
i'm second breaths
saves me time
we've been here we've been here then
there's nothing there's nothing
grabbing uh
syringe following dan
losing hope oh my god this minus five
hope
and wherever i found a i found a vent we
can get it to it i'm trying to reach it
wait how do you get to that vintage one
stacking stuff
i keep walking into the same room over
and over did you guys click all the
buttons in here in the arm room yeah
they did
all right
i have no idea
all right guys because it comes
uh found my way to vent
in all right progress progress this is
good this is huge
big progress
big hole
guy hitting the head by vent ouch
all right i'm plugging you in the vent
i'm pulling in
[Music]
was
i don't know where that get with this
though
yeah you do it then what do you do move
aside here we go oh my god he did it
first right easy dub
he did it first right no cops
look at these look they're all the names
there's so many fuses i found out the
views we have 20 fuses oh there's an arm
in here have you gone on all right
what's your [ __ ] uh
how do we lower this
all right so i'm in my comms i'm next to
you guys
we have fuses someone grabbing i'll grab
an arm i'll grab arm i'll grind my mom
how do i get out of here now guys
there's no arms to spending we got
something's wrong something wrong what's
happening gotta press button
oh that takes me back up okay yeah we
stuck
no no you push the button again and
it'll raise you back up guys i need fuse
gotta press buttons
guys
all right uh any one more fuse
thank you
i got the fuse oh yeah put it in
three fuses done three fuses
done what is the button huge uh let's
find out communication guys guys
community columns comes comes comes i
mean i'm in the bathroom i'm in a
bathroom
he's in the bathroom amazing in the
bathroom i'm looking at a surgery sign
trying to grab it doesn't work
i'm looking in the marine posting i'm
looking in the corner because i don't
know what to do and i'm waiting for you
guys to do something
oh the legs are up here
nice little kid room here now get down
to this one
you got a teddy bear he's got a teddy
bear okay
oh i can get the arm out i can get the
arm now this is huge huge
no i can't get there i'm i was wrong i
was incorrect
i made the wrong push the buttons on the
roof i made a wrong assumption
good good you're good get good
all right all right all right i'm
pressing buttons
i'm in the shower i'm lost confused
i'm alone
we've all we've all been there my dude i
got the arm this is huge dubs wins
i'm grabbing the arm and i'm coming over
with a smile on my face boys
got tons of arms coming through guys i'm
lost i don't know where the way back can
we get clowns
come in with a lot of guys i am lost
guys i'm lost i'm lost i can't oh here
they come
i hit the mother lode boys all the arms
all the legs
i'm stuck because you took all the
elevators what do i do
communicate where are you i am in the
arm press the button again
okay coming to get you come and get me
operations oh i press i press the button
operation save pewdiepie thank you all
right i
i'm on the i'm on the i'm pressing that
oh
where's he on where's here i'm back at
my mic
i got i grab it hey get your arm
comes
leg
left leg
this is a leg all right i'm juicing him
i'm juicing him
do you see him juice them get juiced
oh huge dude
oh my god it's alright mate i got i took
care of it i took care of it i took care
of it i took care of it
no scope the legs no scope that like
wait which one was the right arm i mixed
them up all right uh right foot here
right foot right foot right foot this is
right foot
got a right leg
three ready two one removing leg
oh that was sleep that was clean that
was clean that was clean all right we
need the arms i forgot which one is the
fresh one uh they're right here
oh my god all right uh okay we'll do one
each one still yeah do one each one each
should we start uh start with your skin
okay guys guys comms please talk to each
other with never three two
[Music]
the client is still alive baby surgeon
simulator clan let's go
all right did we get the outfit did we
get the outfit
foggers hell no dude it took us so long
16 minutes
oh we went too bad
14 was the cap
you almost did the blood loss right too
close yeah because i i that was the one
eye thing i had
no good job good job no honestly there's
no eye in a team guys so honestly like
pie yourself pat yourself right now
that was great comes i gotta say gray
comes
real good
i don't know if i can do another one
but all right
i have to stop because mary's gonna go
to bed
all right all right good comments good
comments good comes there all right so
from what i gotta ken has to
all right we're going back to menu i
mean it's
it's 9 20 p.m and she's
extremely extremely there's extremely
pregnant lady um
i mean that's fair sorry
thank you shoot that was fun that was
fun
fun guys i think we saved a lot of lives
i think yeah we did it honestly give it
here give it a
give it a good cv for a future career
it's so good
oh i gotta check out the new outfits
all righty i'm gonna jump out of here
fellas we'll talk to y'all okay all
right kiss this is me dan yeah you too
all right well i guess
that's it
it was fun playing with you today we
should do more sometime we
yeah definitely yeah yeah
old time zone gang and [ __ ]
you gotta take advantage
tickles tickles
all right
that's comms
those calms
those good cubs
oh man
all right
guys thanks for joining
i pissed off ken beyond recognition
but we had good comps i feel like
camera's back now
oh yeah check out new uh tuki huksai
collab
super super good [ __ ]
oh this has been on this whole time
i wish i had more cards to unbox like
that was so fun yesterday
check out surgeon simulator guys
link is in the description super fun
game to play friends one to four players
a youtube classic
certain simulator too baby
make some maps
it's kind of cool that you can make a
[Music]
make your own
maps well this dude has a camera
but if you play it i got you got to make
sure you have good comms just so you
know
speaking of good calms i'm gonna get
going martin into my boots and stuff as
well
and have a blessed day good night and
all that
yeah
all right bye
you